الى تطورات في مدينه نابلس في الضفه
الغربيه حيث قال الجيش الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي ان قواته اعتقلت عشره
فلسطينيين من انحاء مختلفه في الضفه
الغربيه الليله الماضيه المقابل لاعلنت
وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه استشهاده شاب
الفلسطينيه نيس خليل البالغ من العمر 20
عاما متاثرا بجروح اصيب بها برصاص قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي في راسه وذلك خلال
عمليه عسكريه استمرت لاكثر من سبع ساعات
في مدينه نابلس بالضفه الغربيه وفجر جنود
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي منزل عائله الاسير
اسامه الطويل في حي رفيديا في المدينه بعد
ساعات من الاقتحام الذي تخللته مواجهات
عنيفه واصابات وسمع خلاله صوت اشتباكات
بالرصاص وتعتقل اسرائيل الاسير اسامه طويل
بتهمه تنفيذه عمليه اطلاق نار
اسفي عن مقتل
احد في
دير شرف غرب نابلس في اكتوبر تشرين الاول
الماضي
مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد العمري وليد اذا
ما كان بالامكان ان تشرح لنا بالضبط ما
يحدث في الضفه الغربيه
ما يحدث في الضفه الغربيه واخره الاجتياح
وقتل الشاب انيس خليل انيس وتفجير شقه
عائله
الفلسطيني الاسير المعتقل اسامه الطويل
الليله الماضيه وفجره هذا اليوم هي حلقه
اخرى في اطار مسلسل متواصل منذ شهر نيسان
ابريل من العام الماضي في اطار ما تطلق
عليها اسرائيل عمليه كاسر الامواج
والهادفه بالاساس الى القضاء على اي شكل
من اشكال المقاومه الفلسطينيه واذا ما
عدنا الى الحصيله لما يجري فانه بسقوط
الشاب خليل انيس الفجر اليوم والليله في
مدينه نابلس ارتفع عدد الشهداء
الفلسطينيين الى 165 وبتخريب وتفجير منزل
عائله اسامه الطويل المتهم من قبل قوات
الاحتلال وهو اسير متهم بانه شارك في
تنفيذ عمليه قتل فيها جندي اسرائيلي في
قربه شرف
يكون قد ارتفع عدد المنازل التي دمرتها او
خربتها قوات الاحتلال في اطار انتقامها من
عائلات المقاومين الى ثلاثه عشر ويضاف
اليها نحو
323 اخرى من منشاته ومنازل كانت قد دمرتها
بذريعه عدم الترخيص وهناك نحو ثلاثه الاف
نحن نتحدث عن ارقام من بدايه هذا العام
فقط هناك نحو ثلاثه الاف جريح ونحو ثلاثه
الاف وخمسمائه
معتقل او حاله اعتقال منذ بدايه العام
الحالي فما يجري هو اشبه يمكن القول اشبه
بحرب تشنها قوات الاحتلال ضد الفلسطينيين
في اطارها قتل ايضا 20 اسرائيليا بينهم
مستوطنين وجنود بهجمات وعمليات فلسطينيه
مختلفه فالضفه الغربيه تشبه تحديدا شماليه
الضفه الغربيه نابلس وجنين
وكما يطول كان ايضا اريحا كان لها دور في
ذلك هو اشبه بحرب متواصله هذا الليله وقبل
ان ينتصف الليل كانت قوات كبيره قد دهمت
مدينه نابلس واقتحمتها
وتوجهت الى حي رفيديا حيث عاصرت على مبنى
من خمسه ادوار هناك وفجرت الشقه السكنيه
ودارت مواجهات في هذه المواجهات اطلقت كره
الاحتلال النيران فقتلت الشاب خليل انيس
شكرا جزيلا لك مدير مكتب الجزيره وليد
العمري تحدثا الينا من رام الله